here we are this is the reason live
stream I'm your croakie voiced host Nick
Gillespie joined by my colleague reason
TV Zach weismiller and today we are
talking with Angela McArdle who is the
national or the chair of the national
libertarian party we're going to talk
about how the midterms were for the lp
uh the political landscape in general
and uh we're going to go through
libertarian party successes and failures
and what comes next uh between now and
the 2024 election so Angela thanks so
much for joining us
thanks so much for having me great um
you are living in Texas now right
I am I have been here a little over two
months in uh in the great great state of
Texas in the city of Austin all right
and um as uh do you find it Freer
already than California where you
previously resided
sure that everyone in Texas disagrees
and says Austin is the worst place I
could have picked but I'm loving it so
far well I hope you turned out the
lights in California because I think you
might have been the last person living
there it seems like everybody's leaving
so I yeah I I wish
born into what it is now I wish them a
lot of success staying exactly where
they are let everyone else be the ones
to leave
so you want to build a wall That's what
I'm hearing between California and all
the eastern states yeah I think that the
best argument for closed borders is not
Mexico to the United States it's
California to anywhere else fair enough
okay so let's talk about the midterm
elections uh you know that are still
unfolding because there's a number of
major races we don't know what's going
to go on that's going to take a while
but as far as you can tell right now
we're the midterms good for the
libertarian party
I think it's a mixed bag we had some
really exciting wins we have made some
gains with ballot access we got some
people elected at the local level and
most importantly I think we we are part
of the national conversation in a way
that's incredibly profound and
meaningful not just a handful of hit
pieces here and there on one state
affiliate
um we we are the Talk of the Town and I
think that that's really good
what are some of the um the wins uh you
know the kind of local races and things
like that what are the ones that you're
most excited about
Bill Schultz in Kentucky I think is a
really great one it's it's an
interesting juxtaposition over
to some of the conversations that have
happened and unfolded over Arizona Bill
Schultz ran for city council and he was
I don't know if he was the top vote
getter there were seven candidates
running I believe for six positions and
last I saw he was at the top he was
endorsed by Thomas Massey so that was a
really fun one to watch
um the winds unfold we've had someone
get elected to the Board of Education in
Nebraska I believe his name is Jeremy
Dick had a couple of magistrates Justice
of the pieces in Kentucky Shannon
deniston David Harriman we had a mayor
elected in Colorado Aaron lamb so
congratulations to him several more city
council wins in Nebraska and Kentucky
um what else what else more wins I
believe we had a Tulsa city councilman
elected in Oklahoma Grant Miller so
that's really notable still waiting
oh go ahead still waiting to see what
happens with Jeff Hewitt's race
yeah so I noticed that there was a lot
of Kentucky and Nebraska represented
there uh are this just particularly
fertile is that particularly fertile
ground for the libertarian party for
some reason
I think it is I think there's a cultural
issue there and I think there has been a
shift where we've been able to
capitalize and sort of fill a vacuum one
of the things that I'm going to be
working on with our state Affiliates
over the next three to four months are
really detailed granular post-mortems to
understand the political landscape in
all of these areas and to see what we
did right and what lessons we can use to
transfer and share with other state
affiliates
what is the benefit of um you know
winning races at the local level you
know a mayor seems kind of self-evident
or maybe a city council but you know
things like Board of Education or
whatnot
um you know because uh a lot of people
are attuned to thinking about okay you
know the lp will matter when it is
placing people in Congress or the senate
or whatever
so there's a to unpack here one is that
I do not believe that past
Administrations
at the libertarian party at the national
level have done the work to get a
long-term strategy in place
and it is really important for our
candidates and members to understand
that if you want to be taken seriously
at the state and federal level you need
to have political experience you need a
resume just like if you were you can't
walk into JPL or NASA and say well you
know I've been waiting tables a long
time you know let me let me out the let
me have the controls
you've got to start you might be able to
do that at the FDA or the CDC but not
right yeah if you have a good friend so
we've got to start at the local level
and another thing that many of us
learned during lockdowns when we were in
blue states with red areas or
libertarian areas like like Hanford
California is that you have the
opportunity to stand down and
essentially nullify tyrannical edicts
that come at the state level
and so you can make a profound change
another thing you can do is you can save
taxpayer money you can change policies
and you can start to start to really get
Grassroots involvement engagement these
are also the places where you're much
more likely to engage with people who
are passionate and interested in
engaging in the political process and
you know I love all of our philosophical
Libertarians to death
but the reality is people who are very
well read and sort of play the role of
pundit are usually less likely to be
politically engaged political engagement
you need to go and meet at where it's at
so
um having said that and thank you that
uh really clarifies a lot um let's jump
to the higher level races where the
libertarian party is you know in the
National conversation uh first and
foremost let's talk about Georgia where
Chase Oliver in the senate race has more
than covered us the spread between
Raphael Warnock and uh and uh Herschel
Walker and has forced a runoff
um uh Chase got uh about 2.1 percent of
the popular vote there of the vote there
um is he simply a spoiler this is what
you hear and I'm sure you you must get
this in Spades but when I posted a
couple things about hey look Chase
Oliver like Shane Hazel another Georgia
libertarian a couple years ago you know
who helped force a runoff in 2020 in a
senate race uh you know like look at
this he's he's really making an impact
and everybody's like no this guy is just
a spoiler he is uh making sure that a
you know a Soviet communist is now going
to be the senator from Georgia how do
you respond to or I guess first what did
Chase Oliver do right
um to get to a point where he's he's
impacting that race so I believe Chase
Oliver spent a lot of time walking his
district and talking to people so that
might be a good place for us to start
you know actually engaging with the
people who are supposed to vote for you
and not just assuming that you'll have
their vote
um
let's see here so
the reality is he was running against
two terrible candidates
sure Warnock is you know from a
Libertarian perspective the man is a is
a hardcore socialist maybe he's a sweet
guy he's a pastor it's nothing personal
but he does not represent
anything that I would identify on the
freedom scale right Herschel Herschel
Walker's whole campaign was just full of
incredibly unpalatable personal
controversies yeah you've got a someone
who's espousing conservative talking
points with a rumor that he got his
girlfriend an abortion so that's that's
going to be a strike well at least he he
did pay for it so at least he's a
gentleman right yes yes kind of goes
maybe along the lines you know with the
all the allegations that his son aired
with him abandoning his family so that
not getting the family man Vibe and for
conservatives that's going to be a huge
turn off there were also allegations
that he lied about military service it's
just a never-ending mess and I've looked
into it and I can't really make sense of
what's true and what's not and he has
zero political experience yes so maybe
he's you know
I don't think that he's he hasn't got
much of a Competitive Edge over Chase
definitely right but how do you how do
you respond to like this tweet that I
pulled up from the red-headed
libertarian who is the co-host to Tim
Poole
um she says this is why everybody hates
Libertarians it would be funny if Ralph
Warnock were not a communist and so you
know uh first of all do you buy that uh
uh Raphael Warnock is a communist and uh
if so you know are you enabling kind of
the worst of two evils as as she puts it
there sure so I don't know if he's a
hard carrying communist I'm sure he is
trying to push the Overton window in
that direction no no confusion there but
this whole spoiler talk in Georgia
really doesn't make any sense because
they literally have a second bite at the
Apple you chase Oliver is not going to
be in the runoff election they get to go
at it again and what's really incredible
about this is now they have to compete
for libertarian votes and there's a
couple of ways to look at this right
what values does Chase's bows and what
was his race about that are going to
actually appeal to those voters and and
then are people going to actually try to
pull that so it might have been that
chase was more culturally Progressive
and that people were turned off by
Herschel Walker I don't actually know
yet we won't know unfortunately until we
get the results
um
we also don't know if people will simply
stay home
because there are a lot of people
obviously who didn't like either
candidate hence they voted for the
libertarian and I think that's really
important to recognize that they don't
we don't know that chase actually pulled
votes from the GOP we will know we will
find out I think it's also kind of
communist Vibes to say that one party
owns the votes of another group of
people you don't own anyone's votes
that's that's one of the GOP issues is
you know when it comes to certain
policies and certain thought processes
they get it just as just as socialist as
the other party does
you know part of Chase Oliver's appealer
at least the way he talked about it and
I spoke with him a fair man at the Reno
convention uh which where you became the
uh chair and where the mises caucus did
the Reno reset you took over the party
he was critical of the mises caucus
rhetoric and in his campaigning he
talked very much from an older script to
kind of Gary Johnson Joe Jorgensen
script is saying you know Libertarians
when we're talking about retail politics
are basically socially liberal fiscally
conservative do you think that is I mean
does his success such as it is does that
show the power of that message
particularly when you're at the at the
point of an election where people are
trying to make sense of okay I know what
Republicans are I know what Democrats
are and I find both of these parties
contemptible and then here's this guy
who's saying you know I'm socially
liberal and I'm fiscally conservative
and he and he gets enough to throw the
action into a runoff
I think it did have brought appeal to
the voters in Georgia and so I'm really
happy that it did there and we'll dig
into the metrics afterwards and see how
that worked out in other races like the
Pennsylvania Race For example where you
had a hardcore mises guy do something
similar although maybe that one's even
more controversial since it doesn't look
like that's going to a runoff
uh which in the senate race or the
governor's race in the senate race in
Pennsylvania again again with just two
truly awful major party candidates and I
realize we're talking about the lp here
but you know God damn it if the
Republicans Or democrats are going to
[ __ ] and moan about LP candidates not
being serious when you have John
fetterman who I know a bit and I'm
friendly with but really should not be
running for office and Dr Oz who is not
even a good fake doctor on TV for God's
sake
um you know there's something there it's
shocking that someone who is a literal
TV personality for many years
gave such an incredibly poor performance
on TV I uh I just going out of that I
thought you know what I feel so
encouraged there was hope for the
libertarian party because the quality of
candidates coming out of the GOP and the
Democratic party are in such incredible
decline like that we can only go up the
bar is low
um you know let's talk about Arizona
which is another state where the
libertarian in the senate race between
the Republican Bike Masters and the
incumbent Democrat who had won to fill
the end of John McCain's term a couple a
year and a half ago or so uh Mark Kelly
the astronaut
um Mark Victor was the libertarian Party
candidate and he dropped out of the race
a couple of weeks ago and said you know
I I offered to talk to both candidates
uh and Blake Masters called me and uh I
dropping out of the race and all of my
people who were gonna fight for me
should vote for him
how do you feel about that as the head
of the lp
um you know how did just that decision
sit with you
well one thing I'd like to see going
forward is more communication between
some of our candidates and state
Affiliates and in States like Alabama
and Illinois and Indiana and
Pennsylvania
the candidate affiliate relationship is
very tight very solid and we didn't
really see that in this particular race
so that's a that's a lesson that we can
learn
going forward
um are you going to require if I may
like I mean well and and I realize you
know it's no no political party has
control over their members and the
libertarian party probably doesn't want
to exert Total Domination but are you
going to try to you know extract
promises and commitments to libertarian
party candidates that they are not going
to drop out during the general election
and say oh yeah vote for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I think a better way to approach
that would be to just ask them what
their plans are and then everyone can be
prepared accordingly I'm not going to be
able to nor do I desire to control
everything that everyone does but one of
the things that I can do as a national
leader is is just set an example and
also provide resources and an incentive
for them to be in better communication
with us
yeah I was just going to ask you know
what do you think that the function of
the libertarian party is in a race like
that because you know you had somebody
uh like um Dave Smith throwing his
support behind Blake Masters and then
shortly and calling and calling the
libertarian candidate a clown actually
right right and then uh shortly after
Mark Victor drops out
um you know I think we might you know
Dave and I might probably would disagree
on whether that was a good move for the
libertarian candidate but in principle
the idea of using your leverage as a
third party candidate to kind of get
some concessions from one of the major
candidates doesn't seem like a terrible
idea
um how do you think about that when is
that appropriate
um and was it done the right way here or
could it be done better in the future
I think it could be done better in the
future
so I don't like to lean into the the
spoiler strategy I think the way we need
to approach that is to just deal with it
on an individual case-by-case basis my
personal goal is to become the minor
party in States like Alabama where one
of the two major parties has just
basically abandoned it and walked away
and said it's a lost cause but if you're
going to have two tight races I think
that it presents an excellent
opportunity for Libertarians to push the
Overton window in the direction of
freedom and make that part of the
national conversation so that's really
what happened to Georgia so let's say
let's say that
in Georgia Chase had decided not to run
at all there would be no conversation
about libertarianism there would be no
conversation about Freedom or about
trying to actually
get what voters want it would just be
the same tired red versus blue argument
with two rotten candidates Arizona was a
little bit more unique because Blake
Masters is someone who's associated with
The mises Institute and had an
endorsement by Ron Paul and pays a lot
of lip service to a lot of libertarian
policies
yeah he also specifically said at a
national conservative conference just a
couple months ago libertarianism doesn't
work and he seemed to get Mark Victor's
commitment merely by kind of saying oh
and you know I I carried a copy of mises
as human action around when I was in
high school or something like yeah so
you're not I mean to Zach's Point you're
not saying that there there aren't times
where it might make sense for the
libertarian to say I will push my voters
to go with the candidate the major part
of candidate if they say this or that is
going to be my first legislative
ambition
ready I'm not ready to commit to that
yet I think that this is a situation
where it's sort of worked out
accidentally but again I didn't enjoy
yeah would you say and I'm sorry to
speak over you but that in this instance
Mark Victor gave it away without even
getting a ring or something like that or
a promise of a second date he basically
was just ah whatever well did you watch
his interview because he did he did have
a conversation with McMasters
there was was there any back Channel
pressure from people within the
libertarian party to facilitate that
just because the timing raised some
eyebrows in that this prominent
spokesman for the music says it and then
I don't know a week or so later it
happens right yeah there are no back
channels that I was involved in and I
don't want to speak on behalf of the
Arizona libertarian party but as far as
I know there were no back channels there
and they were not happy with the outcome
so I I did not endorse Blake Masters I
am critical of his comments that he's
made about the drug war and kind of
suspicious about some of the stuff with
the border wall again these are just I'm
just sort of speculating on some of that
stuff but
you know I'm sure he's I'm sure he's
better than than a Democrat but that
that's not the standard that I
personally hold myself to and that's not
the standard of the libertarian party
can I ask just very quickly to follow up
on that um you know that that's kind of
true in a lot of races right that or in
almost every state where people will say
well you know I I don't like the
Republican but they are so much better
than the Democrat
why you know what's the role for the
libertarian if that's kind of a
generally agreed upon understanding
well we need to be there at their
advocate for individual liberty and for
better economic policies and and and
better gun rights
especially at the federal level I mean
we saw a lot of that stuff decay under
Trump's Administration he did not follow
through on his promises I think you know
different arguments have to be made at
the state and local level but at the
federal level my goodness like
Republicans have grossly mismanaged our
finances and we saw Federal Gun
crackdowns increase under Trump's
Administration so you know I I'm very
happy that Republicans are less engaged
in lockdowns and mandates they certainly
came out of the gate the same Pace as
the Democrats and they improved but
there's a long way to go between the
libertarianism and just like standard
GOP
can we cycle through a couple of these
questions that have come up that I think
are relevant to what we've just been
discussing from the audience one does
Mark Victor's move to this is from Chuck
G does Mark Victor's move to drop out
and endorse Masters portend any further
defections of LP candidates
I don't
know I don't know how the candidate
didn't approach that it's been a been
controversy within the party yeah I just
hope that there's not somebody who's
like hey you know I read the Moon is
your heart is a Harsh Mistress give me
your vote
I really hate The Giving Tree I deserve
the libertarian candidates votes uh nice
dream asks or says uh Chase Oliver had
the most success and yet the lp mises
Twitter calls him a hater and a leftist
what a joke
um that kind of goes to Nick's question
of there's this division here between
the faction that just took over and a
kind of irony that the most talked about
libertarian uh from this cycle is a guy
who kind of uh went in the other
direction
um you know how do you feel about that
is there
um
some sort of reconciliation that is
possible between the factions
um well let's unpack that question a
little bit the most success so
that metric is arguable quite honestly
um he had the most media attention
uh Eric Gerhart produced a similar
outcome in Pennsylvania except they
didn't have a runoff right
um obviously I don't run the mises
caucus Twitter so I don't know how
recent that comment was I didn't see it
uh I think that what we're going to have
to see is that we need tailored
strategies for different states and
different areas and I've always been
very open to that and I think that it
has been a failure of past
administrations to not be open to the
fact that different states need
different tactics
is it true too and Zach you might know
this off the top of your head because
you've been looking at different races
but it does it seem that the Senate is
kind of the place you know we're and
we're not at a point yet where the
libertarian candidate is going to win
but that Senate races seem to be
tailor-made for this kind of you know
edging your way into the conversation in
a way that congressional districts
aren't usually that close and you know
Governor's races typically aren't and
the presidential race can be but you
know it's kind of interesting that uh
because Shane Hazel two years ago in
Georgia forced you know I and I still
see people saying you know the reason
why we have communism under Joe Biden is
because Shane Hazel pushed one of those
you know Senate races in Georgia in 2020
to a runoff
um thereby you know screwing it over as
if Donald Trump and the Republicans
themselves running shitty candidates
that you know they don't deserve any of
the responsibility but is the Senate
like a place to put bets on how to get
more media attention for the libertarian
party yeah I mean I'll just say I was
looking through the races and I chases
was the one where you know the
libertarian candidate was the quote
unquote spoiler I think there's one
house race in Montana where the lp
candidate covered the spread but the
Republican one in that case uh so
um I don't know
um what the pattern is there but Angela
might be poised to answer that question
so I think the Senate is more of a
zero-sum game and it's more transparent
than it is because it's not there's 435
Congressional Representatives elected
you've got a hundred Senators
um and it's interesting that you would
bring up Shane too because Shane ran for
this what the same position right in the
same state just a few years ago same
outcome so maybe it's not about socially
liberal fiscally conservative yeah maybe
it's that people genuinely have contempt
for this two-party process and don't
like the candidates the state of Georgia
keeps putting up it's interesting though
too because he was running for governor
this time and the governor's race which
was supposed to be super tight so you're
like okay maybe we're gonna have this
again
um was not Brian Camp has uh won pretty
easily over Stacy Abrams and I think
Shane was polling around one percent or
so so it might be a function of timing
of messaging as well as the particular
race yep it's very possible
um so this does to go back to what uh
Zach was talking about it you know but
there is this kind of ongoing
yeah I don't you know what I I don't
know it's that it's a conflict exactly
but like there's this question of what
is the party for and is the party Justin
Amash in a series of uh tweets within
the past few weeks said you know the
function of a political party is to run
candidates for office and win office and
he was responding to various people
including Dave Smith
um who are saying no you know the
libertarian party is really about
growing a constituency for Freedom or
for libertarian ideas
um Zach do you have a clip that you
wanted to run that relates to this or
yeah because this is this kind of goes
back to the okay go ahead sorry
but
sorry I think you're breaking up for a
second there okay uh yeah this is from
uh when I spoke to Angela Beck in 2020
when she announced uh that she was
running for the national chair position
uh this was on the heels of the Joe
Jorgensen campaign where she got about
one percent of the national vote and
this was Angela kind of laying out her
vision for the libertarian party when
you try to water down your messaging to
appeal to everyone I think that when you
try to water down your messaging to
appeal to everyone
you sort of appeal to No One Angela
McArdle is the chair of the Los Angeles
libertarian party who plans to run for
chair of the National Party in 2022
which she says should be less Gary
Johnson and more Ron Paul when you look
at the general composition of the
Liberty Movement not just the
libertarian party it looks a lot more
like Ron Paul than it does Gary Johnson
and I don't know a lot of Libertarians
who tell me that they were inspired by
Gary Johnson did he let people know the
party exists yes but did he light a fire
in anyone's heart no
yes so the question out of there is just
what is the what what do you view the
function of the party as there's a
question in the comments that kind of
cuts to the chase here please weigh in
this is from Matthew Geisler please
weigh in on if the lp is a party first
with the goal to win races or if it is a
pack first with the goal of education
and advocacy
yeah we're not a pack and it's not a
zero-sum game we exist to win elections
and to push the Overton window in the
direction of Liberty and so I take more
of a by any means necessary approach so
at the local level please get elected at
the state and federal level in most
circumstances we are not there yet and
we don't have those capabilities so we
have to operate within the framework of
reality which is a first of all set up a
long-term strategy to get there and have
the humility to understand that we're
not going to get there in two years I'm
so sorry to anyone who thinks we're
going to win the presidency in 2024 it's
not happening please come back to planet
Earth
in the meantime we can use that platform
to advance our strategy grow our
movement and help people understand the
atrocious threats that we're receiving
from Democrats and Republicans when it
comes to inflation or good grief we've
been threatened with nuclear war in
Europe that is on you know not something
that I thought that we'd be seeing over
the next couple of years uh gun rights
civil liberties lockdowns mandates and
so on and so forth so we have an
obligation to speak out about that stuff
especially when we think that we are not
going to be able to actually win at a
national level
well can I ask but I wonder if you uh
you know is that in a way not ambitious
enough or maybe not taking the current
reality seriously enough because you
know you mentioned things like the
Ukraine war the economy I mean the kind
of state of our political like our
political institutions it's it's pretty
dire in certain respects and to say you
know 2024 forget about it
um and we're we're not we're not even
going to worry about trying to be a
contender is that giving up too easily I
mean you think back to uh you know Ross
Perot's kind of the famous example of
like he actually was swinging for the
fences he came out of nowhere and he
made a splash and we're now in 2022
after you know the Trump phenomenon
people can kind of like come out of
nowhere if they have the right message
so are you setting your sights too low
no we're not giving up we're going to go
as hard as we possibly can and you'll
probably see much more
coordinated work and strategy and
enthusiasm come out of the national
party this year than you have in in
previous election Cycles at least in the
past 10 years but I'm looking at I'm
taking an honest look at historical
trends at membership at our budget at
ballot access requirements things that
have we have had to wrestle with over
the last 20 years and I'm looking at
what is a realistic goal for us to
achieve we can go higher I believe we
can go higher than 2020 absolutely I'm
not convinced we're going to get 51
percent of the vote I'm not convinced
we're going to get all those electoral
votes I want us to be absolutely Savage
when we engage in the political process
but also
connected to reality
um to talk about the differences between
being an advocacy group and a political
party and you know granted they're not
mutually exclusive from one another
what does it mean that you know I I
think everybody agrees broadly speaking
that over the past 20 years that Ron
Paul's presidential runs as a republican
as a sitting member of Congress running
for the Republican Presidential
nomination in 2008 and 2012. that
sparked the fire that is still kind of
glowing in the Contemporary libertary
movement but he did it as a congressman
as a successful politician and in the
Republican party and you know somebody
like Gary Johnson a two-term governor of
New Mexico ran you know he attempted to
run in 2008 as for the Republican
nomination
um ended up becoming the uh LP candidate
in a nominee in 2012 and 2016 setting
records at each of those I mean does it
complicate the question of growing the
libertarian party that Ron Paul first
off was a congressman you know with a
decade you know Decades of experience
and he was running as a republican like
how do you how do you take that in his
messaging and then say okay forget about
the Republicans you should be voting for
a libertarian
so what we saw there let me unpack a few
things I think part of Ron Paul's
incredible success as getting getting
elected as a congressman is that he was
a doctor who delivered all the babies in
his district so right I haven't seen
anyone else replicate that yet if
everyone would go out and become OB gyns
that would be fantastic great for the
party
but then let's look at what happened
once he got into office he was able to
maintain office that's fantastic he was
kind of a lone wolf and we've seen other
liberty-minded conservatives have to
contend with similar issues like Thomas
Massey the advocacy work that he does is
incredible doesn't necessarily mean that
all of his bills get passed and the same
happened with Ron Paul then let's move
beyond that to the presidential
elections right Ron Paul is running in
2008 and 2012. what does the GOP do they
block him they try to humiliate him and
they wreck his campaign
so it's a great springboard but I don't
actually see the GOP being a real means
to an end when it comes to Liberty and
so what happened is that everybody who
was part of that movement or nearly
everybody became incredibly
disenfranchised with the Republican
party and dropped back down to the lp
and said at least here I know I could
trust that these people actually care
about libertarianism not like the GOP
who wanted rather put up Mitt Romney the
author of like a socialist Healthcare
policy from his State than than Ron Paul
Insanity so choose sanity you know and
go the lp route
for the presidential candidate of the lp
though you know and Ron of course was
the nominee in 1988 after having been in
Congress for about a decade did not do
particularly well back then
um but you know Gary Johnson you know
leaving aside the question of Bill weld
his running mate who was also a two-time
elected governor of a major state but
does it matter to have somebody who is
actually served in political office
because I know and actually I'd be
interested if if you're willing to talk
about this the the two people who seem
to be you know at the front of people's
minds for the 2024 presidential
nomination are on the one hand Justin
Amash 10 years in Congress so principled
that he voted to impeach Trump uh he
disaffiliated with the Republican Party
became an independent and then
affiliated with the libertarian party
um you know philosophically absolutely
you know hardcore
um worked within the system and became a
Libertarian within the system so you
have that and then you have Dave Smith
who is a podcaster
um and is very funny and has a following
and things like that but you know does
the lack of running or holding office
matter when it comes to the presidential
nomination
I think we're gonna find out so it
looked like it mattered in 2020
or I'm sorry in 2016
but then what we also have to take into
account and honestly I've not been
impressed with the data analytics I've
seen from past libertarian party
administrations so I'm going to do my
best to uncover what I can from from
those past years but he was running
against two of the worst candidates that
could have been put up possibly you have
Donald Trump who people either love him
or find him to be the vilest human being
on the planet and Hillary Clinton who is
referred to as a lizard person and a
perennial loser
um that's not and those are actually
just descriptive terms they're not even
moralistic yeah yeah that's just
when you're running against
a lot of friends in La who were very
very far left who voted Gary Johnson
because they just couldn't stand Hillary
Clinton they would never join the party
they have no interest but they do feel
like a lot of other Americans a
compulsion to check a box on their
ballot and and they did so and to that
extent you know I certainly appreciate
that we got their vote but it didn't
necessarily mean lasting growth for the
party didn't didn't necessarily mean
membership and it didn't translate into
an additional vote for us in 2020. can I
ask very quickly before we go on to uh
talking about your you know how the lp
is doing under your management now it's
been about six months
um you mentioned Ukraine and nuclear war
and this is kind of an interesting issue
you know part of part of what we saw in
the midterms this time everybody
included certainly I was predicting uh
you know a red wave um based on
historical patterns as well as you know
indicators of you know only 24 of the
country thinks it's going in the right
direction Biden is a
ineffective president in his first
midterm elections you know the Democrats
should have lost you know something like
30 to 50 seats in the house that didn't
happen but one of the things that is
interesting is that in cases like
Ukraine you are seeing the old alliances
break down where there are a bunch of
people in the Republican party and in
the Democratic party who are saying why
are we sending so much money without any
seeming a responsibility or
accountability to Ukraine
um you know and you see this group in
the Republican and the Democratic party
joining on that and then there are
Republicans and Democrats who are closer
to each other saying no we have to
defend Ukraine or we have to support
Ukraine is when you look at the broad
midterm outcome you know one way of
looking at the midterm elections is that
neither party got a vote of confidence
in past for the past 20 years basically
every two four six years one party would
gain control enforce the work first
version of their their platform and that
voters would say I'm out I'm going to
the other party and you know we've had
the c-song back and forth of how Senate
White House and this one is kind of
interesting where they're like no I I
don't like Joe Biden but I'm not giving
it back to the Republicans
um how does the libertarian party
perhaps exploit you know this the the
crack up where at least on foreign
policy you know these parties are not
what they used to be
um there are at least large segments of
that I think it's on us to really
distinguish ourselves
so generally we're viewed as taking more
votes from Republicans or Dis Let's call
them disenfranchised Republicans
so we're not like taking their votes but
we're presenting ourselves to them in a
way that is more appealing to people on
the right what I am also seeing though
is that there is a large chunk of the
dissident left who is flipping out and
saying what happened we're supposed to
be the anti-war party are did that just
is does that not exist anymore and so we
are doing actually quite a good job of
appealing to people in that small Niche
section of the left
um I think it's just really important
for us to stand on our principles at
this time you know it's also true and
I'm thinking back a few years to when uh
Robert Sarvis was running for governor
uh Virginia I believe it was
um polling day I mean it's hard to get
exit polling on this but he was a
Libertarian candidate who did very well
and he seemed to have drawn more votes
from Democrats than Republicans so that
is certainly kind of interesting to
think about this bromide that you know
and I mean we've all gotten this in our
you know the different fields that we
toil in for the libertarian movement but
that you know Libertarians are the
little brother little sister of the
Republicans we're Republicans who smoke
pot blah blah blah or who are gay who
are openly gay rather than in the closet
that type of thing but that may be a
fundamental misunderstanding of the
appeal of Libertarians which is that it
is not
uh you know an EPA phenomenon of
conservativism but it you know what I
mean I think we all agree it is
something distinct and it's a question
of how do we make that more you know
there must be a lot of people on the
left who you know when they saw the
progressive caucus send a letter saying
you know why are we doing this in in
Ukraine without any accountability and
then immediately got smacked down like
some of those people probably are like
oh and you know by the way occupational
licensing zoning uh school choice these
are all things that Libertarians have
equally interesting things to say that
actually represent me
absolutely so one of the things I'm
really excited to to share is that we've
been working very closely with the
leadership of the movement for a
people's party which I affectionately
refer to as uh ex birdie Bros they are
definitely on the left economically and
they are a very outspoken about uh their
anti-war position we're working on a
giant anti-war rally together on January
14th and there's a handful of green
party members and independents who lean
who they kind of skew left so that's
something we're all collaborating on
together
um we have also pulled other people from
the left actually into our parties some
of the the hosts of the show uh the
convo couch who are Big Jimmy Dore fans
they've joined the party I got to meet
them in person in Freedom Fest it's
because War nuclear Annihilation kind of
freaks people out and so when they see
someone taking a strong position on that
they want to get on board so I'm excited
about that same same goes in Alabama
we've been working on Criminal Justice
Reform that affiliate has been doing a
phenomenal job and they have pulled a
lot of people from the left the black
caucus especially which is historically
associated with the Democratic party
they've gotten a lot of support and like
these are human issues these are human
issues and they're also libertarian
issues and we're the ones who show that
we care and we're spearheading the
effort to make change
could you talk a little bit more about
the Alabama affiliate and that's working
on Prison reforming criminal justice
sentencing reform who are you working
with because it's yes you know politics
makes strange bedfellows maybe but I
mean this is this is interesting stuff
it does so so the evil uh far right uh
you know mises caucus elected a chair
has been working very closely with
Reverend Al Sharpton's brother Pastor
Kenny Glasgow he is someone who is
really passionate about prison reform
and Criminal Justice Reform he has been
helping to lead from the outside of
prison strike because I don't know if
you guys are aware but the conditions in
Alabama's correction facilities are
atrocious there's about eight prison
guards per 23 000 inmates the prisoners
are expected to run everything
and a lot of them just keep their head
down do their job they just want to get
parole they want to get out but
obviously there's going to be violent
offenders in there who who harm other
people and murder people
I spoke to one of the prison guards who
he just you know older conservative uh
White gentleman complained that he had
to drag bodies out and he didn't know
how long people had been dead it was
just atrocious
so we've been working really closely I
mean I was introduced to him through the
state chair Gavin Goodman who has been
working
working his butt off to get a try to get
ballot access and it's it's really
unprecedented the work that Alabama has
done not just on the ballot access front
but to to like really engage the
community in a meaningful way and show
that we're not like the stereotypical
Monopoly man you know oh I'm going
around kicking orphans and widows like
we're actually doing good work for
people
[Music]
Zach
well
um should we move to some discussion of
the kind of the state of the party
um at this point like what um have you
seen
um
like what what have you seen since the
Takeover of the misos caucus
um uh or the Takeover of the party
um have you seen any positive metrics
um in terms of growth Revenue so forth
2021 we had a little Spike with the New
Hampshire Scandal and then a spike with
the National Convention but we have been
consistently up with earned media
engagement like in a way that's that's
really incredible would you uh just
explain what you mean by that for people
who are not conversing and kind of PR
speak the news
the mainstream news my uh Frenemy the
mainstream news has been covering us a
lot not just hit pieces not just
internal party drama but you know we got
an op-ed published in Newsweek we're
getting quotes out about the war we're
getting quotes out about inflation
they're interested and they're engaging
with us and that's really good can you
just say like from you know in 2021 we
had X number of media mentions this word
now at some level I don't remember the
number in 2021 I just know that it has
literally quadrupled and it was very low
yeah okay great
um what is the Press piece that you've
been involved in that you think is you
know that showcases what you're up to is
there one that comes to mind
we had a piece and Newsweek about
opposing the death penalty that was um
very polarizing it did not it did not
sit well with conservatives so I really
liked that one
it got us quite a bit of attention and
we've had coverage from the New York Sun
that's been positive as well
so I like that we had some quotes go out
that made all over all over MSNBC about
opposition to U.S funding for the
Ukraine Russia War so that was really
good as well
great
um what about membership
um I had how do you go about accounting
you know for membership because there's
the national party and then there are
estate parties but
um are you know are there more members
now than there were when you took over
or how do you account for that kind of
stuff membership has had a slight
decline since I took over
but overall we are still on the up and
up
um that's generally how it goes you'll
see a spurt in membership after the
midterms historically speaking
and there's some membership means
somebody's signing up and affiliating as
a Libertarian and paying dues or is it
yeah
25 a year is the minimum so there's some
interesting stuff to unpack about this
what it looks to me is that for the past
at least six years the only major driver
for membership in the party was to
motivate people to see a change in
leadership
and what that shows is that past
administrations did not push membership
did not seem to Value it significantly
and did not have a plan Beyond internal
fighting to actually grow the movement
not really ideal
so what we're doing now is you know I've
been referred to by some as a peacetime
General right we've done the Takeover
now we're doing the thing we're looking
very carefully at our metrics and data
to see what historically has driven
membership besides internal fighting
what are people excited about right now
we're obviously going to be doing a ton
of research on on the midterms and and
candidacy and and what happens there and
we're going to be developing a strategy
so that we maintain more long-term
growth and I think that we have done
actually a pretty good job of managing
our monthly recurring memberships and
recurring Revenue so that's a really
good sign that you're actually seeing
more stability but I want to see that
stability like expand
Zach do you want to put those numbers
back up or those charts and kind of walk
through and ask any questions yeah
this is just from the LP's latest
financial report uh in September
um the the mises caucus takeover was in
May uh at the the end of May
um of 2022
um so you see there's in terms of active
donors there was a spike in June and
then a slow decline if you look over the
past 20 years it's pretty much flat
Revenue up a little bit although it's
not clear to me if that's uh inflation
adjusted or not I assume not
um so I don't know it seems mostly
everything's like kind of flat right now
um do you you said you expect that to
change after the midterms
um and then what do you hope to like
what is the plan as you look ahead to
2024 to try to you know ramp up for that
um because right now I mean one thing I
assume that you have to take out of the
midterms is
the libertarian party kind of has to
calibrate based on what's happening
within the GOP and within the Democrats
and uh it was kind of like
the the GOP did not sweep in the way
that they hoped they did things are not
looking great for Trump things are
looking Rosier for DeSantis so if
there's a DeSantis uh future for the GOP
um what does that mean for the
libertarian party going into 2024 and
and how do you hope to build momentum
going into a fight like that like at the
santis right Biden bite type fight so
this strategy is a little bit of a
moving Target
so we're going to have to make
adjustments obviously I'm still like
waiting for those ballots to be counted
that might be sitting I don't know in a
shopping cart in a Florida parking lot
you never know uh that is going to be
really telling and revealing for us but
we need to distinguish ourselves very
strongly from both parties especially
going into 2024. if it's a DeSantis that
might be a strong anti-war policy he has
historically been in favor of dumping
tons of money into Israel no offense to
the people living in Israel your
government is not where I want my
dollars to be going
um if it's Donald Trump well that makes
it a lot easier for us I can tell you
that like because uh running a campaign
based on Trump's Revenge that's got to
be the worst political strategy that you
know I think we saw that in Arizona
right the master of controversy aside
Carrie Lake didn't win uh people need to
Let It Go just Let It Go no one wants to
hear about how Donald Trump is still as
mad that he lost the 2020 election
and would you say just for the record I
mean like he lost right I mean this you
know because that's one of the takeaways
of the midterms was that the election
deniers the people who at the behest of
trump were saying loudly Trump actually
won the presidency and it was stolen
from him
um you don't believe that do you I think
there was election fraud and that he
still lost yeah I think there's election
fraud in almost every election sure I
think there was probably more in this
one and I think that he still lost and
that's really unfortunate that's just
how it is you know so sorry that you got
ripped off and you lost that's like a
double bird that sucks but gotta let it
go where you know talk about the youth
appeal of libertarianism or the the
Eternal appeal of libertarianism to you
if you hear this a lot people say
I was a Libertarian when I was younger
and then I had kids or I got a job or I
bought a house blah blah blah but it's
also true that historically
libertarianism has always been pitched
and you know reason has 50 plus years of
coverage of kind of talking this the New
York Times magazine in 1971 or 72
published an article by the future
founder of Wired Magazine about
libertarianism was the next big youth
movement
um are you seeing any movement among
young people because the discussion of
like younger Millennials and gen Z is
that they are either hyper-conservative
and traditionalist or they are totally
socialist and collectivists are
Libertarians uh you know are you
reaching out to young people and is that
successful well I'm really excited that
I'm going to be working with the new
youth caucus chair to roll out youth
engagement
and have college libertarian programs
going that also feed into internship
programs for the national party so I
think that there hasn't been a very
strong concert and effort to engage with
the youth in the past 10 years and
that's just really unfortunate because
young people are generally more open to
new ideas and new experiences and I
think that's why we harness so many of
them or at least we have in the past
so it's just it's going to be on me to
make sure that the national party is
working closely with with people who are
interested in youth engagement
Zach do you want to run the clip about
the embarrassing social messaging uh of
previously this is from the documentary
that Nick and I produced on the the
Takeover in Reno
um and this is just uh Angela's section
from the beginning of the doc
libertarian party is Under New
Management tweeted Angela McArdle
shortly after she became the national
committee's new chair at its 2022 annual
convention in Reno which was attended by
more than a thousand delegates from
around the country and I hate making
promises because I sound like a scumbag
politician but I I will move Heaven and
Earth to make this thing functional and
not embarrassing for you we are going to
change the country
[Applause]
what did you mean by that when you said
we're going to make this thing
functional and not embarrassing for you
oh man so much so I wish we could I wish
I had the screen cap of the social
distancing tweet from the party in 2020
that I could share with you but that's
gone so no more apologizing for the
regime
and when I say that I mean no more
telling people that they need to mask up
in Social distance no more silence on
lockdowns and mandates that stopped
right away
um we're going to build actual
infrastructure for our candidates and
Affiliates because I I feel like a lot
of attention gets thrown at social media
and and I understand why you know like
Twitter is important in the political
world but
we have candidates and and state
Affiliates who message me all the time
and they're like what can I get what
what can I get I think it's embarrassing
the lack of resources that we have
provided for our candidates and members
when you say infrastructure what do you
mean you mean like Signs door hangers
people to go out and walking around like
what what is that infrastructure consist
of training
uh how to how to run a campaign how to
be a Treasurer this is this is like nuts
and bolts stuff that is not that
exciting but it's really critical
because when we go and how to recruit a
candidate right we end up with whoever
is willing to run and I appreciate those
people so much but the reality is we
need to to hone our craft and understand
what it takes to to recruit someone who
is going to be electable and and win a
race
uh beyond that policy positions you
can't just get up there at your city
council meeting with a copy of man
economy and state and expect to appeal
to people but if I'm asking people to
run please literally anyone run and the
only people who are willing to to run or
people with no experience and you know
they're just well versed in the
philosophy what do I do with that I I
have to make the most of it so we've got
to push past that
fundraising how to fundraise you know
how to use elect how to use tools how to
get earned media that just hasn't been
there in the past it just doesn't exist
I the thing that I heard a lot about
during making that documentary was the
emphasis on messaging we're going to
change the messaging and you alluded to
that a little bit earlier uh we're gonna
have Bolder messaging more libertarian
messaging
um embarrass uh messaging that's not
cringe are you do you feel like you're
succeeding at that so far because it is
true that at this point when there's not
a you know big presidential election or
anything like that probably the vast
majority of how people are exposed to
the libertarian party as an entity is
just through its social media messaging
so what do you think of how that's going
I think it's going very well and I
believe that our specifically our
Twitter has gotten us a lot of earned
media engagement I have people asking me
about our position on inflation and War
all the time I think that's a really
good thing
are the numbers up for like the Twitter
account or for the uh the amount of
reach per month or via Instagram or
Facebook or do you have metrics that you
can share to say we're putting out more
tweets and they're reaching more people
or anything along those lines it's all
up I don't have the numbers in front of
me I could certainly send it to you post
mortem but it's up like across the board
uh our Instagram doesn't get enough love
and it's like beautiful and engagement
is up there too it is the Instagram is
uh what's the handle
it's libertarian Party official
Twitter is LP National just for people
well yeah we'll put this all we'll try
and put this in the show notes but Zach
um yeah no it's um you know the
messaging is something that is
controversial within I'd say even within
the libertarian movement and
um I I want to
have you talk about kind of three
different aspects of the messaging that
that I've noticed and um I I just pulled
some example tweets
um so this is uh one uh these three
tweets say you know the IRS Federal
Reserve FBI and CIA are all Wicked and
Beyond repair instead of Reform we seek
to abolish them all
um there are many things that separate
us from other political parties uh but
perhaps the most important distinction
from the union party is we do not hate
you we love the American people we
oppose the American Empire because it's
the enemy of the American people and
then last one here pro-lifers why share
a country with those who just support
the dismemberment of babies in the womb
pro-choicers why share a country with
those who would take a woman's right to
abort away hashtag National divorce and
the the connection that I see between
all these is it's very
um like moralistic and strident language
who are you know Wicked evil uh they're
the enemy they we hate you
um we need to we need a national divorce
um as you know positioning yourself as a
if you're a national party that's
competing with the Democrats and
Republicans
how much do you think that kind of I
guess you know strident and moralistic
language is going to resonate with just
you know the average American coming
across it
I think it's strong and aggressive I
mean moralistic
let's see
let's break this down
I guess we could say that it is
moralistic to call alphabet agencies
Wicked and Beyond repair but yeah I mean
they murder people they murder innocent
people and I think that it's okay for us
to call that out aggressively and I
think that Republicans are finally
finally understanding the dangers of the
FBI after they see their their one of
their favorite guys being targeted
politically
by the FBI I think that this is a sort
of messaging that does appeal to
libertarian voters and I absolutely
stand by it and when we get into the the
abortion thing I mean I think we're
really seeing that that's it's an area
where unfortunately people have just
really got their heels dug in and
they're not they're not inclined to
change their positions
and as moralistic as the pro-life
language might sound
the the pro-choice language is just as
strong I mean they compare us to a
handmaiden's tale like we're living in
that sort of world
there's a lot of fear-mongering coming
from the left so we're just simply
acknowledging it who's your intended
audience with this is it um people who
are already you know hardcore
Libertarians and you're trying to fire
them up is it people who are just uh
kind of disaffected uh politically like
who do you have in mind that you're
trying to reach with with this sort of
messaging
I think that we have several demographic
buckets we've got obviously people who
are already Libertarians or Liberty and
client people who are disaffected and
burned out by the political process
people who are feeling like they're just
now Awakening to the evils of government
and there are people like that who come
from the left and the right politically
is the national divorce language
is that going to be part of the kind of
official libertarian party discourse
because I'm curious I'm not a fan of
that concept and uh Zach did a
phenomenal long interview and and piece
about that with Dave Smith about the
national divorce
um but you know when when you say
something like two people over abortion
it seems like if you're pro-life and you
consider you know abortion murder
abortion from the moment of conception
on murder or you are pro-choice and you
believe taking that away is taking away
a fundamental right to life liberty and
pursuit of happiness of the woman
involved
is that going to lead to people being
like okay we should divorce as opposed
to we should kind of take over the
country and force people to live under
our set of rules because we are
absolutely right whether we're pro-life
or pro-choice well when you have
gridlock like we do I think separation
is the most peaceful sane response as
opposed to Civil War like that's one
thing that as you know the libertarian
hurting does not advocate for is we
don't want to see bloody conflict in our
streets over these sort of issues we'd
rather see people peacefully separate
and that can look like a lot of
different things when when we say
National divorce that's just a really
loose talking point it could be
federalism it could be people just
moving into different states and having
nothing to do with each other and
they're I'm sure there will be legal
battles over abortion and other
controversial topics but I mean my my
perspective is that people need to just
you just got to separate from the people
that you have those levels of
fundamental disagreements with So when
you say National divorce when you say
National divorce and secession you're
not saying the complete dissolution of
the US government
that's not the official like position of
the libertarian party it depends I mean
if you talk to anarchists who are very
staunch anarchists of course that's
going to be their position if you talk
to people who are just more small
government they're going to look at
federalism so it's just really open to
interpretation like we don't have an
official position on National divorce is
there still is there room in the
libertarian party for non-anarchists or
is it at this point an anarchist
Organization no we've we've got
something from years past called the
Dallas Accord that makes our official
position that there is room in the party
for people who are anarchists and people
who are Advocates of small government
and it'll it'll probably always be that
way and it'll certainly remain that way
under my leadership
I want to ask in the National divorce
who gets custody of the national debt oh
right that would be a fun thing to fight
over
um the nuclear weapons are a more
interesting question to me but right
yeah yeah we don't and we don't have
terms are not settled yet I feel
national parks would be the easiest
fight
I don't know I think everybody wants
them right uh for whatever reason if
only so the uh you know so the other
parent doesn't get them you know that's
another set of tweets that I that I had
here uh have to do with you know
so-called wokeness diversity Equity
inclusion is a racist Marxist scheme
made to divide people along imaginary
lines of privilege
um if it's Marx's class Consciousness
applied to the modern workplace and you
shouldn't have to deal with it to
provide for yourself or your family
um there's no place in the Liberty
Movement for woke marxists or Cathedral
centrists
um so this there's clearly an appetite
within the new leadership of the
libertarian party to go after this
broadly defined concept of wokeness
um how does that relate to
libertarianism and um just advancing uh
Liberty in the United States and in your
mind
so there is no room for communism in the
libertarian party spoiler alert and I
think that how do you define communism I
mean is it actual State ownership of the
means of uh production or perhap what is
communism in that sense State ownership
of the means
orchestrated
plan to remove individualism and
individual liberties and replace it with
government
like the whole spectrum of them my
personal view is that wokeism is
mainstream Marxism
okay so would a diversity seminar in a
workplace constitute Marxism or
communism
um the an employer required uh diversity
seminar is that something that the
libertarian party should be concerned
with
well to the extent that it's Shifting
the direction of public policy yes
and they're you know not everyone in the
party agrees on this but we all kind of
see it for what it is and we're alarmed
and we're like that's not good that's
not the direction we want to go in and
we have to thread the needle carefully
and sometimes we can be heavy-handed
about it when we talk about it but we
don't want to see individualism
crushed
um under the guise of equity and
fairness because that's what happened in
communist China and that was obviously
disastrous and you had millions of
people die we never want to see that
repeated
um that this this category I would just
call kind of you know the the juvenile
type trolling I I mean I don't know
about the Epstein didn't kill we are the
Epstein didn't kill himself party that
that maybe is its own category but um
you know replying to Elizabeth the
Warren with this picture promoting
Jeremy Kaufman's
um Wars gay video
um I mean I guess the the general
concern here is like is this kind of a
professional serious image uh or or is
that just not is serious just the wrong
way to think about how the how you want
the libertarian party to come across is
kind of the humor and a little bit of
juvenile trolling part of part of the
strategy
I mean you could do both right we can be
serious and professional and
occasionally have a little bit of fun
Elizabeth Warren has made herself a joke
she should not have leaned so heavily
into the race narrative and so I think
she's fair game uh Jeremy Kaufman we're
certainly not retweeting everything he
says uh but he has put out some really
polished and impressive videos and I
appreciate a lot of his video content
what does it mean to say and I've seen a
lot of quote tweets from the lp national
account about Epstein about Epstein's
black book I mean it just what is the
interest there in terms of from a
national party some of those Tweets in
just to be a little bit uh harsh I guess
I mean that's like those tweets are
something I expect from the stakem's
account or Arby's I don't know like it
seems odd coming from I mean like I
don't I don't know about you but I'm
kind of concerned that we might have a
giant government agency withholding
information on sex trafficking of
children when it's an international ring
and no one has been provided with the
list of clients like that freaks me out
I I think it's okay for us I think we
should definitely talk about that if the
government is covering up an
international sex trafficking ring and
and child abuse I want to know and tons
of foia requests have been filed by
people from all different political
backgrounds and they haven't been
forthcoming on it I think that's really
low-hanging fruit for us
okay
um let's
um talk about the lp strategy for the
next
two years
um you know and obviously you I mean
you've talked about elections matter and
that's the organizing principle or the
kind of calendar of of the lp
um but what are you what are you hoping
to accomplish between now and 2024 when
the presidential elections
um should get under what
so we adopted a strategic plan a couple
of months ago and essentially what I
want to get is I want to recapture the
numbers that we had in the late 90s and
early 2000s
there was a strong emphasis on
membership and I think that that's
important so we're gonna put some inside
baseball tactics on on accomplishing
that over the next why why is it
important why is it important to have I
mean numbers and active members like
um
can you just talk a little bit about why
that's that's important and why did that
decline
members are donors they are candidates
they are volunteers your campaign
volunteers there are volunteers that run
State Affiliates membership is really
important
that declined because for whatever
reason past leadership stopped
emphasizing it and I think there was
also a real struggle around September 11
2001 when people freaked out because we
were staunchly we were supposed to be
very strongly anti-war and the people
were terrified and so they did we did
see uh lapses in membership as people
jumped on the you know blow up the
Middle East Trade unfortunately yeah
so we are
I think it's important for us to regain
membership because I think it's very
healthy for the party
okay so you're going to work to uh
increase uh membership and make people
more active and part of the group what
else are your uh big plans
usually increase our finances
so we're taking a very conservative
approach right now
because I want us to have a balanced
budget and I want us to have a budget
that we stick to and that's not
something that the party has been good
at over the last 10 years or so and we
did note in one of the slides that I
could put up um it looked like your
revenue and outlays were converging
again which is a good sign right yeah
yeah it's it's stable right now I want
to see continued in criminal growth
so we don't have any you know no
disasters right now we're going to make
some very conservative projections and
then obviously I want to go above and
beyond that but we're not going to bake
on something that isn't already within
our sites what about things like uh
ballot access that's always been a big
issue for the libertarian party are you
still concerned about it since you're
kind of you know throwing in the towel
on a presidential election like or does
ballot access kind of just fall off uh
you know from a priority standpoint why
spend money getting on the ballot if
you're not you know win it okay so we're
not throwing in the towel no owl is very
much with us you know not being thrown
anywhere ballot access is essential if
we want to get the message out from the
presidential platform but that that's
really essential
can you talk about
um I you know I I'm talking to you from
New York City uh the New York LP and
actually all third parties in in New
York
um really kind of got screwed over in
the past couple of years this was one of
the things before Andrew Cuomo was
ignominously kicked out of office for
sexual and proprieties uh as opposed to
killing people you know but you know I
guess any means necessary right anything
that works in them out of office but he
changed the ballot access requirements
like how do you deal with that because
it does seem and this is certainly
something every time Libertarians do
well and say like you know you get a
hundred thousand votes and the you know
the the line for uh ballot you know
standing ballot access was 90. nobody's
like oh it should be 120 or 150 or
whatever like how how do you how do you
work to actually make ballot access
ubiquitous and and regularly
so I am literally working on ballot
access in New York right now by working
with some staffers for Republican
legislators
so I think a big shift that needs to
happen in the ballot access conversation
is lobbying every state is different
though so in Arkansas lawsuits are
effective and lobbying is not and a lot
of other states we've seen that lobbying
is more effective Tennessee last year
they had a bill that died on committee
no died on the floor but was arguing I
was being argued but it made it out of
committee to get ballot access because
Tennessee has not had third-party ballot
access since the 1960s so we saw some
progress there I believe in Georgia
where it's probably going to take the
same thing and in Georgia it's going to
be a tough battle and it's probably
going to be tougher right now but we're
just going to suck it up and do it
um what happened to Larry sharp in New
York was incredibly frustrating and I've
also been in talks with other minor
party leaders to to collaborate on that
but and Angela I guess the reason the
reason I was I'm asking I was asking
that question is you said earlier that
the the idea of trying to run to compete
in 2024 is ridiculous and I mean you
know you talk about a lot about the the
Ron Paul campaign as an inspiration I
mean when Ron Paul was running in the
GOP the people who were behind that they
believe you know that you had a shot and
he almost won one of the early primaries
when he was running
um but if you're kind of going in from
the beginning saying this isn't really
about you know trying to win
first of all why what is the point in
spending a bunch of money on ballot
access if it's kind of just more a
message campaign why not just write like
a a write-in campaign
um and then secondly what is why would
people
um want to vote like what's the selling
proposition for someone to vote for a
candidate um who's not really you know
seriously running
you are seriously running this is a this
is a total false Paradigm you can be
absolutely serious while understanding
that your chances of winning are
astronomically small
uh you have a lot more credibility when
you're on the ballot people take you
more seriously there is a drive and a
motivation to go a lot of people want to
have a protest vote write-ins are it's
really challenging to do a write-in
campaign and it just does not have the
same energy as a campaign that it's
official when when there when it's
official there's just like some more
magic there not just for the voters but
for the people running for the campaign
volunteers like it's very important for
morale it's also important for down uh
down ballot tickets as well so there are
people who want to run to the federal
level and the state level and they want
to do it and for for many of the same
reasons and it's important to try to
make that possible and if we let it slip
away for too long it makes our long-term
game much harder so we have to sort of
be paying attention to things in the
here and now while also planning for our
long-term future and if I want to see
the presidential numbers incrementally
grow over the years so let's say we want
to take a modest growth approach I want
to get three percent this time then 5
percent if I want to grow up by two
percent and then eventually start
growing up by fives and tens we've got
to start somewhere so we're going to
start with the low numbers we're going
to have the humility to recognize the
the difficulties that are set before us
but the determination and long-term
Vision to see it through that's what I
intend to do
um
we're gonna start wrapping up but um do
you have a preferred candidate for the
2024 presidential race
do I have a personal preference
preferred candidate yeah yeah I'd like
to see Dave Smith get the nomination but
you know as National chair I'll be
really open about the fact that I'm
going to work with whoever gets it and
I'm going to make sure that that person
gets just as much attention whether it's
valid access you know retweets uh
National appearances I will make sure
and I think that that's something that
did not happen in the last
Administration and that is really
frustrating why do you think Dave Smith
would be good at accomplishing these
goals that you've set out are good good
for that purpose I think he's a very
skilled messenger
and I think that that we're going to
need someone to really make us like
clearly the alternative to the others
not just the lesser of three evils
one other just structural question that
someone brought up a few people have
brought this up is will there be a push
from the lp this is from libertarian
Dave for alternative voting methods such
as ranked choice of voting I think it's
gaining momentum among the people we did
see a number of ranked Choice voting
initiatives do well
um this election cycle does that factor
at all into your strategy
uh yeah ranked Choice voting did well in
Colorado I believe I don't know if it
was a state or a local measure but one
of them passed and the libertarian party
of Colorado had been advocating for that
we actually had a ranked choice to
voting speaker at our lnc quarterly
meeting
um just a few days ago so my personal
attention to focus has got to be on our
candidates but I am probably going to
constitute an alternative voting ad hoc
committee soon to make sure that that
issue gets attention and that is not
something that's left by the wayside
a related question from Chuck G is do
you think Oliver Chase Oliver would have
done better in a ranked Choice scenario
do we think he would have been second
choice for most Walker or Warnock voters
yeah I think so
I think that chase I think that Shane I
think Ryan Graham Eric Gerhart everybody
probably would have done better if they
could have been a second choice
how do you feel about it yeah
because this person gave us ten dollars
so why not Brock last name Angela what
candidates support resources does LP
National have for local state and local
affiliates
so over the last few months we doled out
some dollars to candidates who asked for
it so that was nice which is not
something believe it or not that the lnc
does normally
talk about uh some confusion about what
the purpose of the party is I got I came
under Fire for donating to candidates uh
whatever
uh big bad Angela who hates uh candidacy
and elections uh beyond that we are
working right now with a candidate
support and affiliate support committees
to put together much more meaningful
trainings I appreciate all the trainings
that we've had in the past I want to
make trainings even more accessible and
uh really emphasize Treasurer trainings
we're going to also work on
helping State Affiliates understand how
to cultivate and recruit candidates
we're going to work on
inter-party communication
we're going to be rolling out this
aggressive post-mortem after the
elections and providing our candidates
and Affiliates with that data I think
will you share that with the public as
well I don't know yet
wait for
the word sort of uh you know an
interesting situation right which is I
want to share all of our success and
information but then I don't want to
make it so open to the public that we
just blow our entire strategy for
republicans and Democrats so there will
probably be portions that are redacted
and portions that are available publicly
um you know when the mises caucus took
over when you became chair there there
was a lot of bad blood
um and you know some Affiliates have
disaffiliated I guess with the
libertarian party the National Party et
cetera
um do you feel like that bad blood is is
receding or is you know is coming back
or what steps are you taking to kind of
stitch together a bigger constituency or
have you reached out to people who are
like Angela you taking over is the worst
thing that's ever happened
um how is that going
so I haven't reached out to a lot of
people who haven't have expressed
intense hatred for me personally I think
that's probably not a shock uh New
Mexico we've already got a new affiliate
affiliated so that's that's kind of
handled itself
um I think things are settling down what
I had hoped and what I think is
happening is that my commitment to
candidate support during the election
has smoothed over a lot of people who
were skeptical so you know like I've
I've poured a ton of attention into
States like like Alabama I've tried to
to be very
tried to give a lot of attention to
Indiana and Illinois and some other
states that don't have like a strong
mises majority to show them that I
actually do care about your candidates I
want to make sure you guys are getting
promoted I want to make sure that you're
getting attention and also that we're
learning from you because you know how
to run a strong campaign and I think
that that's going to be the glue that
holds everybody together is my
commitment to people who are serious
about elections
great
um Zach do you have anything else that
you want to ask or raise I just want to
point out uh there are some fans of uh
Angela's strategy in the comments Bob
wild fish win local spread message at
National that's the plan and it's a good
one
um and there's one last good question
from the comments here that uh I I think
would be my final contribution here
which is uh Brian Sutton Angela what do
you think of the idea of focusing a
presidential campaign on one certain
State Utah Wyoming are similar to turn
it Gold by winning in that state what
would be the effect over the following
four years if that happened
um that's kind of the the strategy that
you know Evan McMullen pursued in Utah
he was like I'm going to put all my
resources into Utah didn't work out that
great for him but uh I don't know have
you ever thought about that
I mean it's an interesting thought
experiment I can tell you that the rest
of the state Affiliates would be
incredibly offended if I did that so
I've got to manage a lot of people's
different needs you know different
personalities and resources
uh I do think though what we're going to
be doing is we're going to be working
really closely with State Affiliates who
show the energy and enthusiasm and say
that they want to work closely with us
and that I am optimistic that it'll sort
of look like a bell curve right there
we'll we'll grab the early adopters over
the next election cycle and then we'll
see others start to follow in the same
pattern and finally we'll get to the
stragglers at the end and I think
yeah they're sorry there is one last
good question here that I think gets to
the root of some of what we've been
talking about in terms of audience uh
from free men Die free reality check for
the lp progressives are entirely
indoctrinated into the totalitarian
thinking they view conservatives and us
as equal enemies that answered they
answered that question for who to bridge
with
is that how you think of it in terms of
building coalitions as well
you know you you when I talked to you
back in 2020 you you basically did say
much of the progressive left is like
we're wasting our time trying to reach
out to them
um is the you know mises caucus strategy
really more of a like kind of
coalitioning with the the disaffected
right
um and if so
um how do you compete with you know the
GOP on that kind of playing field
there's the disaffected right and
there's the disaffected left so I would
say that the only change I would make to
that statement is is that it's
mainstream progressives are entirely
indoctrinated and then
yeah I think a lot of I think a lot of
people would you
we would have administrations with these
people up against the wall holding guns
to their head and they would still
believe in the system it's very much
like the people in the gulaga Alexander
Solstice describes as saying if I'll
just be good then they'll accept me back
and I'll go back to my little job within
the Soviet Union there is a breaking
point for a lot of people though and I
saw it during mandates I saw it with
people who had adverse effects to the
vaccine who were 100 on board and like
the first people to get vaccinated and
then when they had a reaction and they
were ridiculed by family members and
friends for experiencing a very real
medical crisis they started to question
everything else that they had learned
and they had believed and I think that
while I want to say on the one hand like
some of these people are just a lost
cause the reality is
I don't want to look at any individual
as a lost cause and so I think that
they're just much further uh out there
with uh our ability to reach than some
of the other people do you think though
generally and I mean I've heard this a
lot over the years that there is more of
an affinity between Libertarians and
conservatives or or right-wingers
generally speaking and you know and this
is why Ron Paul for instance was a
republican
um you know as opposed to a Democrat or
something and on Election night I went
on compound media which is a right of
Center group and you know there were no
there were no results it was early in
the evening there were no results to
talk about yet so it just became kind of
okay let's [ __ ] on the libertarian
because Libertarians in their mind only
exist to take some votes from
conservative Republicans and you know
give elections away and
um you know how do you how in a world
where somebody like a Ron DeSantis seems
to be winning a lot of the culture wars
that some of the mises caucus people are
interested in and advancing you know uh
uh you know a variety of um kind of
corporate uh regulations and other
things like is it you know how
you know who on the right do you pick
off I guess is what I'm saying because I
think you're right you know there's
certain people on the left they're never
going to be libertarian no matter what
and you it's a waste of time to try to
talk to them there are some people are
there who are the people on the right
because there's a lot of Republicans you
know forget you know they're just not
changing their brand right um who who's
what's The Sweet Spot on the right
I think so I think the reason that we
tend to skew right as Libertarians is
because we are more rational and there
are people in the GOP who generally
behave with higher degree of rationality
versus emotionality now obviously when
we get to certain topics like the border
wall you see emotions get really hot but
generally speaking that's how it goes I
think that when you lean into that
really hard
then there are people in the GOP who are
willing to take rational
views on their policy positions and say
you're right this is actually not
libertarian this is this does not serve
the best interests of our nation or is
bad inflation is bad and I have the
self-awareness to recognize my party has
failed in those areas I think that those
are the people that we pick off from the
Republican party can we just as a final
question unless Zach has something
Angela I don't know that I've heard this
story from you but how did you become
libertarian I was just thinking you know
while you were talking
um and when I first read the political
science literature on how people form a
political ideology I was stunned to
learn most people kind of believe what
their parents believe
um because parents were not political
and I was like no I I mean they had no
idea what libertarianism was but how did
you become a libertarian
my my parents were very political and
they still sort of are
um my father growing up was a pastor of
Christian and Missionary Alliance Church
and so I grew up in a traditional
conservative home with the exception
that I was exposed to people from around
the world all the time and the framework
that I was exposed to those missionaries
and people who came and visited from
other countries is that most of them had
stories about being horribly persecuted
in communist countries I've met people
as a child who crawled out of Pol pot's
Killing Fields after being attacked and
shot and ran across the border and
survived I I met people who survived the
cultural revolution in China and so for
and survived Soviet Russia and had been
oppressed and thrown in gulags over
there so I have always been suspicious
of government
um but just more from a Christian
perspective now you know I decided I was
a Libertarian when I was a teenager with
a very you know like low information
awareness of what that was was a
republican who was okay with weed and
gay marriage
um and then I read G Edward Griffin's
book The Creature From Jekyll Island
a few years after that which gave me a
world view imploding uh paranoia and
painful awareness of the dangers of
Central Banking and the Federal Reserve
and then a few years after that Ron Paul
ran and I realized lo and behold there's
a bunch of other people who are paranoid
about Central Banking I'm not the only
one and saw that the GOP was not the
path forward for getting that message
out and that's when I started to look
more into the libertarian party instead
of just you know like well that's a box
I check occasionally now it was like oh
it's a thing you know so that's sort of
an act in three or four plays I guess so
thank you that's really interesting
thank you uh Zach you have a final
question yeah and it's interesting to
hear your kind of ideological background
there and I I can see how it this this
kind of suspicious view of the state has
has grown over time and probably with a
lot of justification and that comes
through through and kind of the messages
that are coming out of the libertarian
party now and I think it's good to be
suspicious and even a little paranoid
about creeping authoritarianism
um
my final question I want to ask you just
and I'll give you the last word here is
there's that side of it there's the
identifying the problem there's the you
know calling out the authoritarianism
um there's criticizing things even
sometimes yes it's Darkly moralistic
terms but then there's also in politics
I guess the idea of putting forward a
positive vision of the future and what
are you going to offer that the
Democrats or the Republicans aren't um
and how is life going to be better if
Libertarians are um you know running the
government what
is that Vision like how would what
what's your kind of Grand Vision for the
libertarian party and like the positive
Vision that you would like people who
are absorbing messages from the
libertarian party social media accounts
or candidates to take away
well we're still working it out but
right now it's that individualism
matters and we want people to be
prosperous and have the opportunity to
thrive and so when we talk about how we
uh hate inflation and we're afraid of
War what we really are is we're
pro-prosperity and we're pro-piece and
we want to see a world where your
children have a safe and healthy place
to live in the future we want there to
be hope for the future and so that's
what we want to convey
all right thank you so much Angela
McArdle the chair of the libertarian
National Committee of the libertarian
party thanks for uh thanks for sharing
your view of the midterms and your hopes
for the next couple of years with us
it's really you're so welcome
so uh that was Angela McArdle Zach wise
Miller thanks for joining me and uh we
will see people again uh next Thursday
for a reason live stream thanks